wcgw not sitting down properly what's
wcgw do i know that
oh what could go wrong not see is this a
reddit thing see
okay
not sitting down properly what could go
wrong
here we go
every
a hell yeah dude
wait
they made it did anyone get hit
oh wait what the [ __ ]
how did he even
what does his head was going to get hit
he sat down
oh he's not even there yet dude wow that
was an optical illusion for a bit dude
this guy sat down and the pole this is
unreal
why was that pole so [ __ ] low to
begin with dude
this seems like a [ __ ] really bad
idea
i mean
paul is
i don't this is not his this doesn't
even look like his fault to me
do you guys understand what i'm saying
like why is it so low
oh because he's on the oh cause he's in
the bout what they call the bow of the
boat because it's up it's up front and
oh that's great dude that's great
amazing dude i hope his cell phone got
all [ __ ] up it's his fault deserve it
scale i will say
it was pretty funny but then also
they shouldn't have the poll there dude
ah that one pisses me off that's a three
he didn't deserve that man to get all
wet with that [ __ ]
wow it's not often we have a low
deserved scale but that's good it's good
we need to know what the scale does we
need to see how the scale massages
itself here we go another one just
[ __ ] click that
one great already clicked it uh here we
go here's another one uh what could go
wrong if i annoy people on a busy
underground train
wow you mean a subway
[Music]
this guy needs to get his ass kicked
[Music]
oh the build-up of this is
oh oh wow he touched the guy's face
oh
no way dude
oh my god dude
that is great
the guy is yelling
some of the most british [ __ ] i've ever
heard in my life i don't know what it is
but it's so jose moshe
jose oh it's a [ __ ] soccer team or
whatever football
joe
oh the other oh then that guy deserves
to get his [ __ ] head locked off
honestly dude and he is standing there
in the [ __ ] subway they call it an
underground train i guess
[Music]
so drunk and i guess his girl's there
but we don't know but she's not doing
[ __ ] so honestly she deserves it too so
then the doors open
and the guy just
tosses him out he's so drunk that's
hilarious dude
look how he does it too
wow the timing of that dude
whoa
is that guy the pet rock
the timing of that was amazing and she's
like very funny very funny dude why
weren't you [ __ ] trying to calm him
down
you deserve it too deserve a scale off
the charts that one honestly wasn't
belly laugh but he totally deserved it
so that's an interesting one right
when it's not
terribly funny but he did absolutely
deserve it i would say that that's a
[ __ ] that's got to be high just
because of how much you deserved it dude
um oh wow he was so drunk afterwards i
hope he got robbed afterwards no i'm
kidding he would have if it was los
angeles but um yeah i don't know i'd say
that's an
eight
that's an eight that's gotta be an eight
unreal okay here's another one
uh
what could go wrong is great
use the force look this is win stupid
prizes okay now all right look
this is what i see
it's a it's a [ __ ]
there's two bottles of jugs here of
water hanging in front of the dude and
he's blindfolded so here's the number
one thing you know he's gonna get
smashed in the [ __ ] face okay and
then you've got george lucas behind him
i guess
here we go
here we go oh okay so okay so he's do so
if you're listening and you're not
watching this is what he does first he
does this like this so already he
deserves it at a top at a [ __ ] 10. to
do that
is so annoying
in any kind of like this is probably
like a [ __ ] honestly a tick tock
challenge okay so he's being
pissed [ __ ] already
and it's [ __ ] absolutely
uh
deserves a lot for doing that because he
thinks he's like in a [ __ ]
what do you call it um
what's that movie
uh
what was that movie american ninja
warrior okay
so here he goes
oh i know what he's gonna do he's gonna
push him and then move side to side
right why's he have a covered mask over
his eyes that's so dumb
yep one and two and bonk hit bonk right
in his [ __ ] nose wait a minute this
is set up
this is set up
this is set up dude you can't [ __ ]
get one by me
i sniffed it out you know why i know
it's set up
because the water bottles aren't [ __ ]
full
the water bottles aren't full
and look at his reaction bonk that's a
fake reaction that's a fake reaction
dude [ __ ] yeah dude he knows he knows
[ __ ] when he sniffs it but that's
good dude because you can't so how much
did you deserve it
you don't deserve the view but you got
the view all right dude fine you gotta
either get rid of him one fire but you
didn't get me dude
maybe first look i might have thought
that um
not so much deserve a scale but it's
just so many bad things happening in a
row this one what [ __ ] one fire says
here we go
everything that could go wrong went
wrong
i love [ __ ] like this dude hold on let
me play it
guys taking a pizza out
i tell
it fell out of the thing these guys are
such bros
look he's got a mitten on
why is the oven over the [ __ ] washing
machine you know
well these guys deserve these guys dude
this is the way they're being they
deserve it so much
oh trying to get it out with a ladle oh
it fell on its face dude the jesus is up
wow you guys suck
[Laughter]
that took 25 minutes and it [ __ ]
that's what happened you know to heat
that pizza it took 25 minutes and that
was the culmination
i love that [ __ ] i gotta gotta watch it
again
first of all the reaction of the of that
is
unreal dude
they scream
when the [ __ ] pizza falls
six inches and nothing happens
they just go oh
that's so funny in itself dude
the reaction bro
this is such a sleepover dude
wow that guy's so annoying
look what they're wearing too one guy's
dressed to the nines and one guy has no
shirt on him
all the onions and [ __ ] fall out
and then they put it on the dish and
they're fat
[Music]
[Laughter]
nobody has ever dressed more euro trash
than these guys it's unbelievable i i
can't even believe it i cannot even
believe it
guys got tight [ __ ] jean shorts on
and a checkered belt unfucking
believable other guy's got no shirt on
and an oven mitt and the other guy's
dressed like a [ __ ] waiter off duty
dude i can't believe how euro trash i
cannot believe how you're trying to
[ __ ] do is unbelievable they deserve
that to happen because of how euro trash
they are that is a [ __ ] 10 out of 10.
if i was there dude
if i was there
after that i would have left so hard for
so long i would have got up no matter
how exhausted i was from laughing i
would have beat the [ __ ] out all of them
dude that's what they deserve honestly
that's what they deserve
and they're for sure if if honestly if
they are not in argentina i will [ __ ]
cut my [ __ ] nuts off and eat them if
they're not in argentina that is the
most argentine no that is the most
salvadorian thing that has ever
[Laughter]
that whole video is the most salvadorian
thing that has ever happened in the
world
[Music]
crazy
[Music]